[Musique]
ce concert aurait dû avoir lieu en mars
dernier il devait célébrer les vingt
printemps des folies française un
ensemble de musique baroque créée à
paris en l'an 2000 par ce violoniste
spécialiste du répertoire du xviie
siècle
là on peut chercher le doubs sur ses
pieds ces deux mesures
est-ce qu'on peut chercher plus de 12 ou
encore l'ensemble s'est installé en
veillant en 2008 et se produit
régulièrement dans ce théâtre
il était donc logique d'y fêter ses 20
ans plus de six mois après la date
initialement prévue
et toujours sans public
nous jouer sans public c'est vraiment
une chose affreuse et ce confinement 7
qu'ovide c'est ça le problème c'est de
pas avoir ce rapport avec le public un
rapport direct avec le public
donc on a encore heureusement là pour
certaines résidences un rapport avec les
collègues avec les musiciens
c'est important mais nous on fait de la
musique pour le public
le concert est donc filmé et diffusé en
direct sur internet pour tous les
admirateurs des folies française et pour
les passionnés de musique baroque en
général la direction du théâtre
d'orléans apporte ainsi son concours
technique et va ouvrir ses plateaux à
d'autres artistes là aujourd'hui c'est
le concert qu'on va faire la semaine
suivante c'est le quatuor diotima qui va
venir enregistrer lui aussi des petites
capsules pour leur coupe communication
c'est aussi l'idée qu'on prépare de 7,9
de cette façon là on prépare l'avenir
c'est à dire que si on attend que
confinement soit terminée que tous les
problèmes soient réglés au bout de on va
démarrer avec quoi
le concert des folies française a
également été enregistrée ce cadeau sera
disponible sur le site de l'ensemble et
sur celui du théâtre d'orléans
[Musique]